The Colosseum was, and still is, colossal.
It's the great example of ancient Roman engineering.
It was begun in 72 AD during the reign of Emperor Vespasian...
...when the empire was nearing its peak.
Using Roman-pioneered concrete, brick and their trademark round arches,...
...Romans constructed much larger buildings than the Greeks,...
...but it seems they still respected the fine points of Greek culture.
They decorated their no-nonsense megastructure with all three Greek orders of columns:...
...Doric, Ionic and Corinthian.
Stepping inside, you can almost hear the roar of ancient Rome.
Take a moment to imagine the place in action.
Romans filled and emptied the Colosseum's 50,000 seats...
...as quickly and efficiently as we do our super stadiums today.